hi I'm Christy smart man and I'm Melissa
Wilson and we're with the University of
Minnesota Extension using manure is a
nutrient source it can really improve
your pastures and cropland while
reducing the need for fertilizers but it
has to be applied properly in order to
protect the environment and
understanding the application rate is an
essential piece of a manure management
plan today we're going to talk about and
demonstrate how to calibrate a solid
manure spreader the first thing you need
to know about manure spreaders and
calibration is that there are several
variables affecting application rates
for all spreaders the tractor speed or
gearbox settings will help determine the
rate at which you apply manure then
depending on the type of spreader used
you'll also want to know the apron or
hydraulic push Gate setting an example
of the setting for an apron spreader is
shown here other important settings may
include the PTO speed and/or the
spreader gate opening settings but
please know that not all of these
settings will apply to every type of
spreader while calibrating keep all of
these factors consistent but make
adjustments if you need to increase or
lower your rate when you're finished be
sure to record the final settings used
so you can repeat them in the following
years
remember that application rates will be
determined by the crop or pasture
nutrient needs as an example regulations
in Minnesota state that you cannot apply
more nitrogen that is needed by the crop
including manure and fertilizer sources
this is why writing a nutrient
management plan and calibrating your
spreader are important there are two
possible ways to calibrate a spreader
the first is the load area method which
involves weighing your spreader with
drive on scales and the second is the
tart method which involves spreading
manure over several tarps and weighing
the manure collected if you have drive
on scales available to you the load area
method is the most convenient way of
calibrating a spreader the only other
equipment you'll need is something to
help measure distances like a measuring
wheel and paper and pen to record the
measurements first step is to weigh the
spreader when it is full of manure and
record the weight
make sure to include the tongue weight
of the spreader
once the Lotus spread way the spreader
empty and record the weight
by subtracting the empty weight from the
full weight you can get the weight of
the manure next you'll need to measure
the area over which the manure was
spread if the area is rectangular in
shape measure the length and width
once you've recorded the length in the
width and feet multiply the two values
to get the area in square feet finally
calculate the application rate divide
the weight of the manure by the area
over which it was spread then multiply
by a conversion factor of 21.8 this will
give you the tons of manure spread per
acre
where does 21.8 come from it is 43,560
square feet per acre divided by 2,000
pounds per ton this will convert pounds
per square foot to tons per acre
we suggest repeating the process at
least three times with the same settings
so that you can find the average manure
application rate if the application rate
is too low or too high make adjustments
to your speed gearbox or spreader gate
opening settings then calibrate again
and that's how you use the load area
method to calibrate a spreader
for that art method you'll need a tarp
for rocks or other heavy objects to hold
down the corners of the tarp a measuring
tape a bucket a scale and pencil and
paper for recording first step is to put
the tarp in the bucket and weigh it
empty before any manure is applied then
record the weight next spread the tarp
out in the field where you'll apply
manure and secure the corners with the
rocks then use the measuring tape to
measure the length and width so that you
can determine the area of the tarp
record these values now you'll want to
spread the menorah most people try to
spread manure as evenly as possible and
avoid skips between application passes
so they'll try to overlap their passes a
bit in this case we're spreading the
manure fairly thick this is because it
is composted it has a low nutrient
content other manure may be spread more
thinly depending on the nutrient content
to account for overlapping passes you'll
want to do three passes with the middle
pass lined up over the tarp make sure
you are spacing each pass the same as
you would when you normally apply manure
once the manure spread carefully pick up
the corners of the tarp and fold the
manure into the center place the folded
tarp with them in or in the middle into
the bucket and place it on the scale
record the weight
now we can begin to calculate the
application rate first you will need to
know the weight of the manure subtract
the empty bucket weight from the bucket
with manure weight this will leave you
with pounds of manure that was applied
next you should calculate the area of
the tarp that thinman or of a spread
over multiply the length of the tarp by
the width of the dark this will give you
the area in square feet the remaining
calculations are very similar to how we
calculated the application rate with the
load weight method divide the weight of
the manure by the area of the tarp then
multiply by a conversion factor of 21.8
this will give you the tons of manure
spread per acre for this method we
recommend doing this procedure at least
three times and then find the average or
use three tarps at once line them up in
a row in the middle pass and find the
average weight of manure on the three
tarps the application rate is too low or
too high make adjustments to your speed
gearbox or spreader gate openings then
calibrate again one question that people
will often ask is how often should I
calibrate my manure spreader we
recommend doing it when the manure
consistency is not the same perhaps when
it is wetter or drier than normal when
you've changed your management practices
like using a new type of bedding or
maybe you've started composting the
manure instead of spreading it raw or
when something changes on your spreader
equipment like a new tractor or ATV or
if something gets replaced on the
spreader if nothing has changed over the
years we still recommend recalibrating
every couple of years to make sure
nothing has changed to summarize
calibrating your manure spreader is an
important step in knowing how much
manure you are applying so that you can
accurately create a manure management
plan using either the load weight or the
tart method is a useful way to calibrate
your manure spreader remember to record
the tractor settings like the speed when
you're traveling and the gearbox and
spreader gate opening settings your
spreader is run by PTO then record the
PTO sb2 this will help you remember what
settings to use in the following years
good luck and happy spreading
[Music]